I'm here with Jame Larkins who's the
founder of Larkins Enterprise which is
an aviation holding company based out of
Atlanta
he just tell me a little bit about the
history of it and what you guys actually
do I was really fortunate I was 12 years
old found out about airplanes and
aviation fell in love with it took my
very it started flying them unlike the
rest of us right yeah when I was 12 but
had a major problem no one in my family
flew I had no connection to the aviation
industry whatsoever it was really
expensive you know the average per hour
flight flight cost at the time was
probably about $200 an hour being 12
years old coming up was pretty difficult
so after a couple about a year of
learning how to fly it got to the point
that I could actually safely handle an
airplane and sell a flight I tried to
lower the cost of flying for myself and
getting an exemption applies only more
before my 16th birthday that ain't quite
worked out so then I realized that if I
was going to continue to fly I had to be
able to make enough money to do it on my
own
and so you started selling training
material that was the first thing right
first thing that I started doing was
selling $30 books and videos to local
pilots by seven of them one hour yes
exactly and that's just gross revenue
right right so a lot more than the day
but overtime about a 10-year period it
evolved from selling $30 books and
videos the buying and selling airplanes
which is amazing so you buy and sell
bootjet and props that is correct and
that's also through Larkins enterprises
but a subsidiary a subsidiary of it
called ascension aircraft so we started
up ascension aircraft a couple years ago
and that's been the primary way that we
sell and lease airplanes and it sounds
like you're doing something even more
remarkable you're kind of doing a
fractional ownerships sort of a period
NetJets I guess for private net jets
flight options for personal airplanes or
private aircraft and it's been working
out pretty great there's been a lot of
companies that have been involved kind
of in this space but we have a couple
unique things that we've done that kind
of create our own version of it and
we've been able to do pretty good
we had a competitor that was involved
inside of the Atlanta area they had a
12-year head start on us we're able to
become number one in market share in
less than 20 months from that's amazing
congratulations so but you were telling
me earlier that so if I have a private
pilot and I want to buy an aircraft how
much does that cost me and how much do I
use that
it depends on what type of airplane you
could go out there and get a 20 30
year-old airplane for 50 to $100,000 but
if you wanted to go out there and get
the world's best-selling single-engine
airplane that's gonna roughly cost you
about eight hundred and fifty thousand
dollars and round numbers the average
general aviation pilot flies somewhere
between 80 to 100 hours a year which is
about the equivalent of three to five
days a month and then the rest of the
time they're playing sitting in a hangar
and they never see it so why not go
ahead and buy a portion of that airplane
that gives you access to it just as much
as you would if you owned it but be
about a third of the cost that it would
be otherwise and how many pilots have
signed up for this program so we have
about 40 pilots in the Atlanta area in
the last 20 months that have signed up
inside of the program and to give you an
idea general aviation for the series
there's typically about 200 of those
airplanes that are sold on the annual
basis here inside of the United States
Wow now do you fly booth props and jets
yes so I get the opportunity to fly wide
range airplanes I've had the opportunity
to fly over 36 different types of
airplanes everything arranging from a
Cessna 172 up to corporate jets and
everything in between
talking to a man who is broken the sound
barrier I have I had that opportunity to
go flying out of the United States Navy
Blue Angels and chance go Mach 1.2 you
literally a couple hundred feet off the
coast of Florida one time terrifying um
more than one of the most amazing
experiences you could ever possibly
imagine it sounds terrifying so if
you're gonna fast forward from here and
I'm sitting down with you here five
years from now are you still doing the
same thing are you still in the aviation
business or is it what's gonna be going
on definitely inside of the aviation
business and I hope to take our
fractional program and instead of having
just one hub base in Atlanta to
hopefully having 20 of them across the
country buy them do you know where your
next hub might be next hubs gonna be
Fort Lauderdale Florida great well good
luck with that and thank you so much for
being here thanks for having me